Ecoute moi Mcfly...
Je ne sais pas où tu as déposé le butin, mais tu vas me le dire tout de suite !
Cette très mauvaise imitation d'inspecteur me permets de dire: Bonjour le peuple des internets !
Nous sommes le quinzième jour de décembre,
ce calendrier de l'avent avance beaucoup trop vite,
mais en même temps c'est plutôt cool, ça veut dire qu'il y a Noel qui arrive aussi tu vois ?!
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un livre, ce genre de livre qui me fait beaucoup rire,
parce qu'il contient des choses vraies à l'intérieur.
C'est un livre de perles, qui rescence des perles du tribunal ou de poste de police,
qui ont été dis, cités, entendus, et c'est deux avocats qui ont fait la recherche pour faire 10 opus sur la police et 10 opus sur le tribunal,
ils en ont extrait le suc, ce qui a donné...
Dorimen... [chante]
ce livre, voilà juste ce livre où on retrouve 400 perles , jusque comme ça, elles ne sont pas commentées,
ce n'est pas le but. Ca se lit tout seul, ça se picore dans des endroits improbables, comme les toilettes par exemple. [rires]
Tu vois... ou dans un train...
Voilà, j'aime bien ça.
Celui-ci on me l'a offert et j'ai bien aimé ce cadeau.
Par exemple on va retrouver dedans: "La victime est superficiellement égorgée au bras".
J'aime bien...!
Ou encore, le titre du livre: "Le pendu est mort noyé".
"L'homme se décida à dire toute la vérité, qui n'était qu'un tissus de mensonge."
Je vous propose donc d'en lire quelqu'uns en vrac
Je ne les commente pas,
juste je les lis, vous les appréciez comme vous voulez,
vous me dites ce que vous en pensez dans les commentaires.
Et si vous les avez comprises, parce que parfois ce sont des erreurs, des pléonasmes, des lapsus.
Et ils sont parfois plus faciles à comprendre à la lecture qu'à l'oreille.
"5 des 2 suspects ont été interpellés."
"Une femme est tombée enceinte après le passage de l'expert".
"Ecoutez monsieur le juge, elle tire tout le temps des plans sur la courette."
"Notre mariage ne tenait plus, il était en pleine liquéfaction."
"J'ai réussi de mettre de côté un petit pécus, mais j'ai tout dépensé, aujourd'hui je n'ai plus rien."
"La femme prenait de l'anorexie à chaque repas."
Je viens de percuté, que j'oublie de vous dire à chaque fois si ça sort d'un poste de police ou d'un tribunal.
Je vais préciser maintenant.
Police: "Il s'avère que la victime et sa femme étaient  cousins et qu'ils avaient peurs d'avoir des enfants avec des problèmes cons sanguins." (en deux mots...)
Tribunal: "Non monsieur le juge, c'est après le divorce que j'ai appris que j'étais enceinte, et j'ai donc fait une chorégraphie."
Pourquoi pas.
Allez, je vous en fait deux derniers qui proviennent d'un poste de police.
"L'incendie a fait 3 morts dont deux grièvement."
Et enfin le dernier, une sorte de lobe story.
Oui moi aussi je peux faire des jeux de mots.
"L'auteur et la victime étaient aussi sourds l'un que l'autre,
et ils ne semblaient pas bien s'entendre..."
Bon, il y en a 400 comme ça.
Et elles sont toutes à peu près du même délire, je trouve ça très drôle.
"Le pendu est mort noyé", je crois que c'est une vieille édition, donc je ne suis pas sûr que vous en trouviez beaucoup.
En tout cas je vous mets un lien dans la description.
Je vous mets également de l'amour en ces fêtes de Noe, parce que j'espère vraiment que cette idée de calendrier de l'avent vous plait.
Moi ça me plait beaucoup de faire ça et de présenter plein de choses différentes qui me plaisent.
Que ce soit des jeux, des livres un peu complexes, des choses beaucoup plus légères.
On peut s'en parler dans les commentaires.
On peut s'en parler le 22 septembre 2018 à l'Olympia.
C'est vous qui voyez. Mettez un pouce si ce n'est pas encore fait,
abonnez vous si ce n'est pas encore fait,
et kiffez parce que je pense que vous êtes bientôt en vacances.
A demain matin, 6H.
Ciao !
[musique]